let's see let's see what we can do here
okay by the way just
a bit of a hint oh not necessarily here
but some of them might help you
um remember i start off with the
definition of just
regular symmetry like symmetry of a
general type right
and we said symmetry is or symmetry is
when and then i gave you a definition do
you still have that there
you got it okay now i am going to give
you a definition
and i want you to hear how similar it is
to the previous one okay and then we'll
unpack it
so rotational symmetry is and here's my
sentence which i'd love you to write
underneath
yours okay is when
you can rotate a shape
right and
after rotating it you will get the same
shape
exactly the same shape in exactly the
same place
right um you get
exactly the same shape and i'm very
pleased that some of you
have used even that phrase because
that's how we're trying to understand
this whole
idea exactly the same shape in exactly
the same
place okay now
lots of shapes that you know
have rotational symmetry okay so let's
think of some examples okay
yes i think this one okay i'm going to
draw a circle up here
i will come back to the circle in a
moment though i want to think of a
simplest i know circle is very simple
but i want to think of a simpler shape
yeah a square
excellent now if you have not um
um thought of that that's okay but i
would like you all to draw a square
okay very important now you remember
before
um i would give a shape and then i would
reflect it across right and then we
would label
we would level the points and then see
what happens okay
so for instance um this shape here right
it's a square i'm going to call it
square a b
c d okay now just like how reflectional
symmetry right
you had a special line and you could
reflect across it and that's where it
was symmetrical what did we call that
special line started with an a
yeah richard the ax is good i had a few
times that's okay
um the axis of symmetry right well when
you rotate things
the ingredients that go into rotation
it's not a straight line right what's
the ingredient that goes into this yeah
yeah there's a point are we actually
drawn in here okay so we call it
the center of symmetry okay bless you
now just like how you have ingredients
that go into
a reflection or rotation right what do i
need i need more than a point don't i
what else do i have to talk about
if i want to have a rotation i need
what else do i need yeah i need an angle
good because
for instance just have a look at this
don't draw this but um just as an
example right
suppose i was to rotate this 45 degrees
45 degrees what would happen okay
well i'm guessing i'm guessing it'll
look something like this
is that about right you can see a a
that'd become a one
right b would become b1 you get the idea
now let's have a look at this this is
not
the exact same shape in the same place
is it right
but a square really does have rotational
symmetry so can someone give me a
suggestion
for how should i rotate it instead 45
degrees doesn't work
what could i do as an alternative yeah
ash
90 degrees okay so i've got my a b
c d here okay so when i rotate it um and
i'd love you to do this as well if
you've got another color that will
really help
this a right where is it going to go
it's going to come around to here it's
going to rotate around this point
okay so a will become a1
over here right on top of b
in the same way b is going to become b1
over here right on top of c
and so on
so now when i connect these all up i
have a very christmassy looking
square but the important thing is it's
the exact same shape
in the exact same place